oh wow that is the only booster i need i
tell you that's
well i do need a we all do it's terrible
news out of afghanistan right i mean you
know we have to report this it's they're
frantically getting people out
evacuating uh and you know we got a lot
out over a hundred thousand thirteen
thousand people in one day i tell you
america not too good at winning wars but
the getting the [ __ ] out part
we're getting a lot of practice at that
so um
but of course there was this suicide
bombing which makes it a giant tragedy
now am i the only one who thinks we did
this completely ass backwards we pulled
the troops out
and then tried to evacuate the civilians
i feel that was a little backwards you
know of course it's a yeah it's it's all
the uh
all the roads leading to the airport are
gridlocked of course the airport is
complete mayhem there's no sanitation no
power
today the promoters of the fire festival
said that is some poor planning
that's when you know
and
robert o'neill he is the navy seal who
claims he the one who
killed bin laden
interesting statement he had today he
said it's time to kill people
this america buddy you're preaching to
the choir
when is it not time here to kill people
our motto should be it's time to kill
people o'clock somewhere
uh
but biden
i think biden's on the same page kind of
because he said about the attackers he
said we will hunt you down and we will
make you pay
so america is no longer the world's
policeman we are the world student loan
officer
uh and
and of course the attack was tech was
carried out by isis k
not a boy band
a variant
the delta variant of isis isis k who
they who don't think the taliban
is hardline enough their motto is a face
for an eye
very hard line
very hard line oh these people are hard
oh they
they make women wear two burgers in case
one rips just
remember the old two-bagger joke
and listen to this a little local flavor
into the story
thank you sir
there are a group of students with some
parents who are stranded from in
afghanistan they are from the san diego
area and these kids are fine
first of all they don't know they're in
afghanistan they have not yet looked up
from their phones
that's good
but wow
that's how bad things are in california
families are vacationing in afghanistan
i mean i mean my father took us on some
shitty summer vacations but
but yeah because this state is always on
fire it's
fire season used to be part of the year
in california now it's all the time like
elections
right
i'll tell you
hard to stay governor of california
not that hard to get elected hard to
stay california elections are like when
your girlfriend says i don't care where
we have dinner tonight you pick and then
you do and she goes not that
so yeah the
election is in a couple of weeks the
ballots are out for our recall election
one of
46 faceless losers
could be the next governor of this state
with a fraction of the vote
and the runner-up gets to host jeopardy
but
let's end with some good news
that you're anticipating i love that
only fans
is staying in the porn business
the rent stays the same
that's right last week i just in the
spot i was reporting there getting out
of the porn business now they are
staying in because their fans would not
take it their fans went nuts
boy there's one thing millennials love
more than canceling the patriarchy it's
women having sex for money that's the
interesting thing
well i mean things are bad enough in
america and nothing worse than when even
your cam girl put you in the friend zone
that cannot happen but uh okay and
finally donald trump has endorsed
herschel walker the great football
player running as a republican in the
senate in the state of uh fourth senate
in uh
georgia and uh herschel walker admits he
has multiple personality disorder claims
to have a dozen personalities wow a
republican with a dozen personalities
and today mike pence and mike pence said
can you loan me one
you